et donc moi je vais quand même parler un
peu de la est mort on avait déjà parlé
il ya deux ans vous aviez invité chez
zemmour et naulleau et on avait déjà
parlé de lyme en fait là est mort quand
même qu'on remette un peu les choses au
point douter mais les pourcentages c'est
0 6% les dépenses c'est lé rapport igas
tout ça donc 99,4 % sont pas pour les
étrangers sans papiers qu eric zemmour
il me supprimer la et me wade moi je
suis dans un hôpital en seine saint
denis votre département préféré
département vous avez donc été je suis
né vous avez grand des départements où
moi aussi alors j'y suis pas né mais j'y
suis arrivé à l'âge de six mois où j'ai
grandi donc vous c'était à drancy je
crois moi c'était à bondy nord on
n'était pas loin et après
clichy-sous-bois donc des quartiers
extrêmement riom et dont il s'était très
riant les peuples non c'est pas vrai
c'est vraiment c'est précisé vrai nom à
dire s'ils sont d'accord mais ça c'est
dur c'est vos souvenirs d'enfance il est
chevalier comme amazon annonce ait
jamais existé
mais morts à la veille ou alors je suis
beaucoup plus vieux blues beaucoup plus
jeune que vous peut-être chandon et donc
il ya huit mois dans mon hôpital donc
faridi denis là où il ya le plus
d'étrangers encore vous le dire c'est
donc j'ai compté on a compté on a
regardé j'ai demandé aux services
sociaux et aux finances cellule % les
étrangers 8% mais sans papiers celui qui
n'a pas la vaisselle emploi talent est
déjà bien sûr pas les étrangers non ça
veut dire que les autres 90 ou 12 % des
gens ont une couverture sociale oui bah
oui bah ça ça veut dire la sécu en frais
oui ou non ils ont des faux papiers non
c'est faux c'est faux ses arrières tout
le monde triche c'est 92 % dont une
grande partie sont des français de
souche comme cyril comme vous et comme
moi merci de me mettre dedans mais moi
aussi moi aussi je t'apporte on est des
français de souche après tout on descend
tous de jeanne d'arc quand vous l'avez
dit bon descendre d'une pucelle c'est
toujours un peu compliqué mais
visiblement c'est possible et drenthe
rue tessin n'ont pas encore non j'avais
pour vous faire signer ses skis et ça
m'a fait marrer quand il en rit on
descend de jeanne d'arc devrais je dire
techniquement il est peut-être bon en
rhétorique est peut-être bon économies
je comprends rien je suis désolé par
contre en médecine des moins bons ah oui
là je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous ma wii et donc donc il faut dire
aussi que cette mesure qui est quand
même votre mesure phare en santé aurait
dû tout si c'est ce que j'aurai du temps
précisé ces mesures sur la santé à merci
merci et donc et donc et donc c'est en
ile-de-france en fait un les deux tiers
sont en ile de france
tous mes collègues qui sont en région
les envoie pas enfin c'est un tiers et
la plupart ils en voient pas et donc
c'est pas la france et je rappelle quand
même pourquoi est on était a été créé la
mmf s'est pas seulement là bas on
arrivait déjà discuté c'est pas
seulement des questions d'éthique ce
n'est pas seulement des questions de bah
on va pas laisser mourir les gens on va
pas laisser à coucher les femmes devant
l'hôpital parce que c'est quand même sa
chaleur mais la juste juste matin où il
ya beaucoup de gens qui nous demandent
ce qu'elle a aimé
étrangers malades ont demandé à être
soigné en france la msp et l'aide
médicale d'état il faut être là depuis
trois ans sarah et ça couvre un panier
de soins c'est-à-dire pas tout voilà et
donc donc quand même donc c'est donc
dans mon hôpital c'est 8% c'est-à-dire
14 millions sur 200 millions à peu près
ses courses et ça c'est 14 millions on
les donne pas aux étrangers on a
l'impression qu'en vous écoute on leur
file des 14 millions et qui vont
s'acheter ce qu'ils veulent non ils vont
à lo passé avec moi le droit d'asile
avec les 400 euros qu'on leur donne ça
c'est autre chose mais ça n'a rien à
voir moi j ai donc et donc ils vont à
l'hôpital et ils sont soignés ça nous
coûte à l'hôpital 14 millions qui sont
couverts par la m e en partie payant si
demain ces gens là ne vont plus elle ne
va pas on va pas arrêter de les soigner
et vous n'allez pas les faire
disparaître d'une d'un coup de baguette
magique on est d'accord je vais vous
répondre si vous me laissez parler et
vous laisser terminer sur ça que je ne
dis rien mais je ne ferme pas les matins
sur la place viendrait qu'on en sache
plus sur le voilà sur le programme en or
mais je l'assumé direction parce que ma
question allait la ceca tant il est vrai
qu on paye et qu'on continuera à payer
parce que la femme enceinte on
l'apprendra le tuberculeux on le prendra
parce que la mta lé fait pas seulement
pour des histoires des tic j'allais dire
mais aussi pour des histoires de
pertinence de la dépense c'est à dire
que vaut mieux prendre quelqu'un qui va
pas trop mal que quelqu'un qui va très
mal parce que ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher et donc ses 14 millions ils seront
je ne pourrai pas les toucher enfin mon
hôpital pourra pas les toucher et donc
on sera en plus déficitaire avec tous
les problèmes qu'on a de ses 14 millions
comment on va faire en fait ce que vous
allez faire c'est tous les hôpitaux qui
sont dans ces coins où les gens les gens
les sans papiers ne disent pas dans le
xvième arrive dans les jeux dans les
coins pas très cher donc là où il ya
déjà des gens pauvres ben vous à les
appauvrir ces hôpitaux et garder
l'argent dans les hôpitaux publics
n'étaient pas publics
du reste dans la france donc ça on
va laisser répondre eric zemmour alors
là et me ce n'est pas 14 millions ça
c'est dans votre hôpital c'est plus d'un
milliard tiens milliards voilà mes chers
milliards en tout- exactement cela c'est
un pur sang mêlé raw 6 % c'est 0 6% j'ai
dit 3 où vous en avez déjà dit dix ah
bah ouais mais elle est désolée c'est un
débat en disant c'est pas un débat là
vous avez monologuer
faire 12 heures
je n'ai faire pipi vous savez on fera
une émission sur vous monsieur gbagbo
maintenant je vais pas besoin là c'est
sûr vous voilà donc les six la laissez
moi parler à leurs désirs euh non mais
dites vous dites vous dit de toute façon
les soignera vous avez tout à fait
raison on n'a pas attendu la m e pour
soigner les cas d'urgence l'aemo je
précise en 1999 donc avant ont soigné
les urgences mais ce n'est pas le sujet
vous dit de toute façon ils sont là il
faut les soigner première erreur en
vérité ils viennent pour la m non très
peu très peu pas voyons non ils viennent
pour la haie mais il ya même des réseaux
on a même découvert des réseaux
criminels de géorgiens avaient relancé
pour refaire les nichons c'est pas dans
le c'est pas dans six est dans la m
maille monsieur demandeurs de soins sont
principalement algérien ivoirien
congolais et puis j'ai dit y avait des
réseaux mais les algériens aussi sso
savez qu'aujourd'hui mon nom je
j'aimerais compte il sera son palais
j'aimerais continuer 70 pas les les
algériens par exemple les tunisiens
attendent leurs trois mois la fin de
l'heure que de leurs types de séjours de
touristes pour se faire surprendre en
soins dans laquelle son jeu vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la eme un tiers de la m e
cd accouchement elles viennent accoucher
spécialement en france non mais c'est
vrai vous avez raison et elle doit je
continue la vie de l'ancien aileron
surveillance oui mais elles accouchent
en france mais alors comme ça à lorient
c'est lors leurs enfants c'est sur le
dos ah ben alors là faut connaître la
loi parce que moi aussi c'est ce que je
croyais non mais je croyais que quand
d'accoucher en monsieur dans le fond
était français oui à 18 ans oui et non
non il faut un point minimum je sais et
c'est pas vrai monsieur bah moi ce que
vous pouvez me laissez pas respirer mais
vous parlait tout le temps
l'hôpital vous n'êtes pas le patron ici
donc c'est oui six mois six mois
oui monsieur nous ne leur dit pas une
connerie simon wiensenthal patron
eric geboers a donc je continue donc
elles viennent pour accoucher et c'est
comme les dialyses il ya énormément de
diamants bien combien
combien combien moins bien vos biens en
tout cas bon mois d'anormal -2 1% mais
vous savez toi c'est le rapport reagan
oui justement
les 10 h 10 les mahdi des maladies le
plus sollicité malades les maladies non
oui
et on met déjà psychiatre et où le dj
les chiffres que sa vie déjà là il n'a
sinon nous n ont pas à se faire soigner
en france de maladies psychiatriques
mais s'ils viennent et qui ont cédé pour
y remédier la course ne s'est pas là et
me fait venir les étrangers premièrement
deuxièmement deuxièmement deuxièmement
il ya quand même quelque chose après
vous devriez être fiers bleu pâle et
j'ai dit non non je parle et je suis pas
fier de dépenser l'argent des français
pour des gens étranges et non je suis
pas fier ça deuxièmement les français
les français aimeraient bien avoir cette
couverture sociale aimerait bien avoir
les soins gratuits parce que un milliard
ça fait 3000 euros pour chaque personne
qui s'épaissit mal à vous le savez bien
oui dit comme nationale comme ça ça
marche parce que par les doutes chez les
français cela émeut on finit là dessus
parce qu on a commencé la tribune il a
su incarner cueilli après son prêt à
aller jusque là et me il ya aussi et
monsieur wargon et dans un hôpital où il
ya aussi les créances non recouvrées
c'est à dire qu'il y à beaucoup
d'algériens de tunisiens et deux
africains fascinée elle utilisait son
médecin qui viennent se faire soigner en
france denis matthey qui ne payent
jamais on le renvoie on leur envoie une
facture en algérie ou au maroc et elle
n'est jamais payer les gens appellent
les créances non recouvrées à sanaa
cellier et monsieur mais si c'est donc
on arrête de se soigner qu'est ce qu'on
fait en pratique qu'est ce qu'on fait
les récents monsieur on ne va pas
exploser mais on ne les rembourse parole
et pas de gbagbo les payer on les fait
payer ont fait trembler vous isoler mais
on les fait déjà payer nos prenons ne
paye pas ses on est dans le royaume
merveilleux où vous les expulser moi
j'aimerai quand on est dans un hôpital
suisse a bloqué ces mois-là l'hôpital
depuis deux ans sur la pandémie mon
personnel il est quand même d'origines
diverses et très varié chants seine
saint denis donc en général j'ai
travaillé dans d'autres hôpitaux le
personnel ressemble un peu à la
population autour notamment les
infirmières à cette soignante des
brancardiers personnages illustres hâtif
les médecins moins les médecins ils
viennent directement de tunisie donc
quand vous me parlez des tunisiens qui
mangera les soins des français les
niayes les îles et donne monsieur barque
je n'ai que des médecins étrangers pour
non moi je voulais c est les et posez
votre question a été posée votre
question et je suis vraiment même le
symbole de la laïcité l'hôpital moi j'ai
pas de voile dans mon service et j'ai
été extrêmement choqué sur votre
histoire de vol parce que moi j'ai plein
d'infirmières plainds internes qui ont
le voile qui n'ont pas dans le service
qu'ils ont à l'extérieur qui font pas de
prosélytisme donc monsieur bac mais moi
j'aimerais savoir ce alors il essaie de
répondre construire cet hôpital merci à
les voir baisser la tension c'est un
podium parce que sa solidité l'hôpital
géré le symbole de la laïcité ça me fait
rire parce que bon on bosse pas oui oui
combien d'hommes refusent que leurs
trames moi ça m'est arrivé une fois
inventé un nom oui c'est marrant les
réglages
deuxièmement vous savez pourquoi vous
savez on est à comparer directement la
je veux dire pour l'alléger c'est ça
justement j'aimerais bien qu'on sache
que vous dites il ya des ressortissants
tunisiens car vous savez désirez vous
avez tout à fait raison à exhaler
pourquoi on a fait venir ses médecins
parce que on a fait un numerus clausus
complètement dingue qui a empêché deux
jeunes français pour un quart de point
un demi point de devenir français le
nouveau-né un médecin
vont l'être aussi en or mais si vous
avez très bien compris donc je viens
médecins ne devenir médecin et je pense
que c'est la première on sait c'est une
erreur dramatique par oui non mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire et qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va déjà supprimé
vraiment ce numerus clausus et on va
doubler la capacité de formation des
médecins parce qu'on a une démographie
médicale qui baissent dangereusement
puisqu'on a beaucoup de médecins baby
boomeur baby boomers comme on dit et qui
vont prendre leur retraite on aura je
crois soixante dix sept mille médecins
dans les années 2020 alors qu on l avait
97 milliards quinze ans